สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันศุกร์ค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 9
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือน
มิถุนายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้วัน
พฤหัสบดี
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 8 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมิถุนายน
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2003 ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันเสาร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่
10 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมิถุนายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้เวลา
20:00 น
:00 น
53 นาทีค่ะ
2 ทุ่ม 53 นาทีก็อีกประมาณ
3 ชั่วโมง
ก็จะหมดวันศุกร์แล้วใช่ไหมคะ
ครูหญิง
ใช่ค่ะ
เที่ยงคืนใช่ไหมเที่ยงคืนพอเที่ยงคืน
เนี่ยก็เปลี่ยนวันเป็นวันเสาร์เนอะเที่ยง
คืน 1 นาที
ก็จะเป็นวันเสาร์ก็หมดไปอีก 1 วัน
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่ชอบวันศุกร์
ครูหญิงจำได้ครูฟ้าไม่ชอบวันศุกร์ตอนครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยอยู่ที่ประเทศไทย
การไฟฟ้าบ้านเนี่ยพัทยาพี่ฟ้า
ชอบวันศุกร์
แต่ครูฟ้าบอกไม่ชอบ
ทำไมผู้หญิงชอบวันศุกร์คะ
อ้าวก็พรุ่งนี้วันเสาร์แล้วก็วันอาทิตย์
ไงไม่ต้องทำงาน
นอนเยอะได้ไง
ไม่ชอบ
ครูฟ้าตอนนี้อยู่
ออสเตรเลียเป็นยังไงนะ
คะ
หนูชอบค่ะ
[เพลง]
ในแบบพอวันเสาร์ใช่ไหมครูฟ้าจะตื่นแบบ 11
โมงก็
โอเคเนาะตื่นเช้าใช่ไหมคะ
พอวันเสาร์
วันอาทิตย์
ใน 1 วันครูฟ้าก็ไม่ได้ทำอะไรมากๆ
ในวันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์ไม่ได้ทำอะไรมากค่ะ
นอนแล้วก็ไปทำงานแล้วก็กลับมานอนแล้วก็ไป
ทำงาน
เราต้องนอนอยู่แล้วค่ะนักเรียนเหนื่อยมาก
นะคะ
ก็เลยนอนๆๆๆ
แต่ว่าวันนี้เนี่ยมันเป็นวันศุกร์ใช่ไหม
ยังเป็นวันศุกร์
วันศุกร์ที่ 9 มิถุนายนเนี่ยวันนี้ก็เลย
อยากจะถามมีคำถามเนี่ยมาถามครูฟ้าว่าใน
วันศุกร์ที่ 9 เนี่ยใน 1 วันเนี่ยครูฟ้า
ทำอะไรบ้าง
ที่ไม่ใช่นอนตื่นนอนอาบน้ำแปรงฟันอันนี้
ทุกคนรู้ทำทุกวัน
ตื่นนอนอาบน้ำแปรงฟันอันนั้นทำทุกวันอยู่
แล้วนะคะ
นักเรียนนักเรียนรู้อยู่แล้ว
แต่ว่าวันศุกร์เนี่ยนะคะครูฟ้าเนี่ยตื่น
[เพลง]
7 โมงค่ะ
2 ทุ่มแล้วใช่ไหม
วันนี้เนี่ยก็ 12 ชั่วโมง
ที่ครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ทำอะไรหลายๆอย่างนะ
actually มันไม่ใช่ 2 ทุ่มนะคะนักเรียน
เพราะว่าอยู่ออสเตรเลียนะคะ
ถ้างั้น 2 ทุ่มก็คือเวลาประเทศไทย
ใช่ 2 ทุ่มนี่คือเวลาประเทศไทย
แล้วออสเตรเลียเนี่ย
กี่โมงหรอคะตอนนี้
ออสเตรเลียตอนนี้
5 ทุ่ม
+
ก็จะบวก
ไปอีก 4 ชั่วโมงก็จะเป็น 16 ชั่วโมง
1 วันเนี่ยมี 24 ชั่วโมงใช่ไหมคะก็ 8
ชั่วโมงเนี่ย
ครูฟ้าทำอะไรบ้างอ่ะวันนี้
วันนี้นะคะฟ้าก็จะบอกว่าครูฟ้าตื่น 7 โมง
ใช่ไหมเคลียร์เคนว่าตื่น 7 โมงเนี่ยนะคะ
เพราะว่าครูฟ้า
ต้องไปโรงเรียน
ครูฟ้ายังเป็นเด็กๆอยู่หรอต้องเรียน
หนังสือ
หนูเป็นเด็ก
เพราะเป็นเบบี้
เด็กเนี่ย
ถึง 12 ไหมอันนี้เด็ก
นะคะ
วันหนึ่งแหละอย่างแรกและใน 1 วันเนี่ยที่
ครูฟ้าต้องทำก็คือไปโรงเรียนเดียวครูฟ้า
อยู่ออสเตรเลียทำไมทำไมธงชาติเป็นของไทย
เพราะครูฟ้ายังจำธงออสเตรเลียไม่ได้นะคะ
นักเรียนอย่าโกรธว่าไม่จำไม่ได้นะคะแต่
ว่าอันนี้คือโรงเรียนใช่ไหม
น้องพลอยก็ต้องไปโรงเรียนนะคะครูบาต้อง
ตื่น 7 โมงเพราะว่า
วัดตื่น 7 โมงแล้วเขาก็ไปไป
ที่รถบัส
อ๋อนั่งรถบัสไปโรงเรียน
ใช่ค่ะไปที่รถบัสนะ
แปรงฟันนะคะแต่งตัวมีแต่งหน้าใช่ไหม
เมคอัพไปที่รถบัส 7 โมง 55 นาทีนะคะแล้ว
ก็ไป
โรงเรียน
ฉันจำได้นะคะถนนไปโรงเรียนเนี่ยถนนไปโรง
เรียนของครูฟ้าแล้วไปโรงเรียนเรียนเสร็จ
แล้ว
ครูฟ้าทำอะไรอีกไหมไปกินข้าวแล้ว
ก็กลับบ้านค่ะ
คุณเวลาไปเรียนเนี่ยก็มีครูฟ้าแล้วก็มี
เพื่อนผู้ชายเพื่อนผู้ชายเพื่อนผู้หญิง
คุณไม่เรียนเสร็จแล้วแบบต้องไปกินข้าวกับ
เพื่อนเลยหรอไม่เรียนเสร็จไปกลับ
เรียนเสร็จ
กลับบ้านค่ะเพราะว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยต้องทำงาน
นะคะ
ครูฟ้าทั้งเรียนแล้วก็ทำงาน
ใช่นี่ก็
บ่ายโมงใช่ไหม
เรียนเสร็จบ่ายโมง
เรียนเสร็จบ่ายโมงครูฟ้าต้องเดินไปขึ้นรถ
บัสให้ทันบ่ายโมง 5 นาทีรถบัสซ้ายหลายโมง
5 นาทีนะคะนักเรียน
[เพลง]
แล้วปกติคุณ
ขึ้นทันไหมขึ้นทันรถบัสไหม
โอเคค่ะเพราะว่าครูฟ้าวิ่งใช่ไหมวิ่งๆมา
ที่รถบัสนะคะ
ก็โอเครถบัส
เพราะว่าถ้าคุณฟ้าขึ้นรถบัสไม่ทัน
ไม่ทันบ่ายโมง 5 นาทีเพราะก็ต้องนั่งรอไป
จนถึงบ่ายโมง
[เพลง]
ก็จะลง
ที่
สถาน
รถเมล์
ขึ้นรถบัสอีก 1 คันคันที่ 2 เพื่อที่จะ
กลับบ้าน
เพื่อที่จะกลับบ้าน
อีก 1 คันแล้วก็กลับบ้าน
ก็จะกลับมาทำงานกับผู้หญิง
ใช่ๆเพราะเราคุยกันว่าโอเคครูฟ้าจะได้ไม่
ต้องว่าตอนนี้มันประมาณก็เที่ยงคืนอ่ะ
เนาะเที่ยงคืนตื่นแล้วแต่ถ้าครูฟ้ารถบัส
แล้วก็กลับมาทำงาน 1 ชั่วโมงแล้วก็
จะได้ไม่ต้องนอนดึกๆแต่วันนี้ขึ้นรถอัน
ที่ 2 ทันไหมคะ
ไม่ค่ะนักเรียนเพราะว่าวันนี้เนี่ยนะคะ
ครูฟ้าเนี่ย
นะคะเรียนเสร็จใช่ไหมบ่ายโมง
ป๊าเรียนเสร็จบ่ายโมง
แล้วครูฟ้าก็มาขึ้นรถบัสบ่ายโมง 5 นาที
โอเค
แต่รถบัสมาถึงที่นี่
บ่ายโมง
[เพลง]
25 รถบัสคันนี้เนี่ยนัมเบอร์ 28
อันที่ 2
เบอร์ 28 นะคะ 28
แต่รถบัสนำเบอร์ 28 เนี่ยเขาจะมาประมาณ
บ่ายโมงยี่สิบห้า
ลงรถบัสคันแรกไม่ทันก็ขึ้นคันที่ 2 ไม่
ได้นะใช่ค่ะฟ้าเนี่ยรถบัสมาถึงบ่ายโมง 25
นาที
28 เนี่ยก็
ออกไปแล้วนะคะ
บ๊ายบายครูฟ้ารถบัส
มันไม่ทัน
ครูฟ้าก็ต้องรอประมาณ
15 ถึง 40 อ่า
[เพลง]
ส่งข้อความมาบอกครูหญิงว่าครูฟ้าขึ้นรถ
บัสเบอร์ 28 ไม่ทัน
[เพลง]
ไม่เป็นไรแต่ครูฟ้าเนี่ยต้องรอมันหนาวใช่
ไหม
ใช่ค่ะนักเรียนคือครูฟ้าอยากร้องไห้อ่ะ
นักเรียนเข้าใจ Feeling ครูฟ้าไหมคะเพราะ
เห็นรถบัสออกไปแล้ว
จะทำอะไร
แต่ไม่ได้ทำ
เพราะขึ้น
รถบัสเบอร์ 28 ทันกลับมาถึงบ้านครูฟ้าก็
ทำงานกับครูเสร็จ
ไปทำงานกลับมานอนใช่ไหมสบายมันคือ plan
นะคะแต่นี่ไม่ใช่ตามแพลนของครูฟ้านะคะ
ถึง 45 นาทีแล้ววันนี้รถบัสนัมเบอร์ 28
เนี่ยเรทด้วย
น่าจะใช่นะคะเรทจนมีผู้หญิงคนนึงอ่ะ
เขายืนอยู่กับครูบาใช่ไหมแล้วผู้หญิงคนคน
เขาเป็นน่าจะเป็นคนออสเตรเลียหรือเปล่าคะ
ไม่ชัวร์นะคะ
เขาเป็นฝรั่งนี่แหละแต่เขาพูดแบบว่า
ลด 28 อยู่ที่ไหน
ก็อาจจะรอนานไหมไม่ตรงไม่แบบเออมาไม่ตรง
อ่ะค่ะใช่ค่ะ
ขอบคุณนะคิดเหมือนกัน
แต่ครูฟ้าก็
นั่งรถบัสมาถึงที่บ้านได้นะคะนักเรียน
พอมาถึงที่บ้านเสร็จแล้ว
ออกไปทำงานเนี่ยกี่โมงอ่ะคะ
วันนี้ครูฟ้าออกไปทำงานประมาณ
3 โมง 15
[เพลง]
รถบัสคุณก็ต้องขึ้นรถบัสใช่ไหม
รถบัสเนี่ยจะมาเวลาประมาณ 3 โมงครึ่ง
คุณฟ้าก็ต้องออกจากบ้านแล้วก็มารอก่อน
ต้องว่ารอรถบัสค่ะเพราะว่าถ้าครูฟ้าไม่
มันไม่มี 4 โมง
คือมันมันน้อยอ่ะค่ะนักเรียนรถบัสมันนิด
หน่อยไงในที่ที่กูฟ้าอยู่นะ
ใช่ค่ะก็เลยมันก็เลยนั่นแหละ
มันก็เลยออกจากบ้านนะคะ
ไปที่ทำงาน
ที่ร้านอาหารนะคะนักเรียน
ร้านอาหารไทยใช่ไหมทำงานที่ร้านอาหารไทย
อันนี้อะไรคะ
อ๋อ
วันนี้ครูฟ้าทำงานที่ร้านอาหารน่ะกี่
ชั่วโมง
[เพลง]
4 โมงถึง
โมงนะคะ
ถึง
10 ถึง 4 ทุ่มเหรอ
4 โมง 5 โมงโมง 1 ทุ่ม 2 ทุ่ม 3 ทุ่ม 4
ทุ่ม 6 ชั่วโมง
วันนี้ครูฟ้าทำงาน 6 ชั่วโมงแล้ววันนี้
เนี่ยนะคะ
การทำงานในร้านอาหารของครูฟ้าเนี่ยเป็น
ยังไง
ดีไหมเหนื่อยไหม
เหนื่อยมากค่ะนักเรียน
เหนื่อยมาก
ทำงาน 6 ชั่วโมงเนี่ยครูฟ้าต้องยืน
6 ชั่วโมง
ใช่
ไม่นั่งเลยเหนื่อยมากแล้วก็คนใช่ไหมคน
เนี่ย
คนมากินข้าว
คน
เยอะมากนักเรียน
[เพลง]
เพราะว่าวันนี้เป็นคืนเป็นตอนกลางคืนเนาะ
เป็นวันศุกร์ก็อาจจะเป็นวันที่เหนื่อย
สำหรับครูฟ้าเพราะว่าต้องตอนเช้าไปเรียน
ตอนเย็นทำงานแล้วพอเป็นคืนวันศุกร์ทุกคน
ทำงานเสร็จก็จะมีปาร์ตี้ก็มาที่ร้านกิน
ข้าวคนก็เลยเยอะมากๆ
ใช่ค่ะคนเยอะมากๆนะคะครูฟ้าก็เลยเหนื่อย
มากๆ
ทำงานที่ร้านอาหารเสร็จครูฟ้าก็กลับบ้าน
แล้วก็มาทำงานกับผู้หญิงนะคะ
ครูฟ้าเป็น Wonder  Woman หรือเปล่าคะ
ทำไม 1 วันเนี่ยคุณทำอะไรเยอะมากๆเรียน
สู้กับรถบัสผู้หญิงอยากจะใช้คำนี้
นักเรียน
ทำงานก็เหนื่อยนะคะ
แต่ขึ้นรถบัสเหนื่อยกว่านะคะสำหรับคูปอง
ใช่
ครูฟ้าต้องไปเรียนใช่ไหมเรียนเสร็จก็ต้อง
คิดฉันจะขึ้นรถบัสบ่ายโมง 5 นาที
บ่ายโมง 5 นาทีเนี่ย
ขึ้นทันไหมแล้วเสร็จแล้วก็บ่ายโมง 25
นาทีนี้รถบัสคันที่ 1 รถบัสคันที่ 2 ใช่
ไหมก็เหมือนสู้สู้กับรถบัสแล้วก็ไปทำงาน
ร้านอาหารทำงานร้านอาหารเสร็จ
เพราะฉะนั้นใน 1 วันเนี่ยถ้าเป็นวันศุกร์
สำหรับครูฟ้าก็เป็นวันที่เหนื่อยเหมือน
กันเนาะ
ก็แล้วใน 1 วันของนักเรียนล่ะคะเป็นยังไง
เหนื่อยไหม
สบายๆก็ comment คุยกับได้นะคะส่วนวันนี้
คุยกับครูฟ้าต่อแล้วเดี๋ยวเราเจอกันใหม่
วีดีโอหน้านะคะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะบ๊าย
[เพลง]